BRANDY AU: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We are hosting webinars daily.
My name is Brandy
Au, and today we
will be talking about
magnifying the value of G
Suite with Chrome Enterprise.
And joining me today
is Christopher Jones.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform,
and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
Let's get started.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
Thanks, Brandy.
So today we're going
to talk about the value
of adding Chrome Enterprise
to your existing G Suite
deployment.
So why Chrome Enterprise?
Because Cloud native
productivity and collaboration
deserves a Cloud
native endpoint,
with all of the
built-in security
efficiency and intelligence.
What is Chrome Enterprise?
Chrome Enterprise includes
Chrome OS, the platform
that powers Chrome
devices like Chromebooks;
Chrome browser, the default
Browser used on Chromebooks;
and the Chrome Enterprise
license, [? a pro ?]
device management license
allowing management
of Chrome devices at scale with
integration to third party EMM
providers.
Chrome Enterprise plus G
Suite means smart, intelligent
collaboration without
compromising security,
assistive experiences that help
enhance end user efficiency,
reduce downtime for your
users, and reduce security
risk from fewer out-of-date
endpoints and data protected
in the Cloud.
BRANDY AU: The value
isn't just imagined.
We engaged Forrester to study
existing Chrome OS and G Suite
customers, and they were able
to quantify these benefits--
30 minutes per user per
week in reduced downtime
due to more efficient
Cloud native products
and increased mobility
that helped avoid costs
from lost productivity; a
15% improvement in help desk
efficiency with device and
productivity suite management
in the same console, leading
to easier remediation;
a $100 per-user in legacy
technology savings,
due to easier rollout
and ongoing management;
and a 20% reduction
in endpoint security
incidents due to Chrome
OS built-in security.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
Furthermore, analysts
from ESG evaluated
how much organizations
can save when switching
to Chromebooks with Chrome
Enterprise, based on the
elimination of common IT tasks.
Total device savings can
amount to $480 per device,
outside of the cost of hardware
and licensing themselves.
BRANDY AU: So let's take
a look at the factors that
contribute to these savings,
starting with security.
With Chromebooks and
Chrome Enterprise,
automatic updates and sure
devices never fall out of date
and always have the
latest security features.
Safe Browsing deters
users from visiting
dangerous sites that may include
malware or phishing attempts.
Sandboxing isolates
tabs and processes
if a vulnerability
does get through.
And verified boot ensures the
OS is a known safe version
every time the device starts.
Since data and profiles
are stored in the Cloud
with G Suite,
Chromebooks can maintain
a negligible on-device
data footprint.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Results
speak for themselves.
We've had zero
account hijackings
using Chromebooks, G Suite,
and two-factor authentication.
For two-factor
authentication, we
have security keys that
plug into your mobile device
or laptop and complement
your password.
These security keys cannot
be broken like old tokens.
Again, we've had zero account
hijackings using this solution.
BRANDY AU: Another key benefit
of Chrome Enterprise and G
Suite is simplicity created
for users when dealing
with Cloud native end points.
Devices boot quickly, usually
in less than six seconds.
Updates run in the background
so the user isn't disrupted
or faced with downtime.
That's up to 30 minutes
per user savings,
according to Forrester.
Cloud-based user profiles enable
users to log into any device
and have the same experience,
making them highly shareable
and making it easy to
replace a broken device
or enable grab-and-go
or loaner scenarios.
And finally, employees save
time on sending versions
back and forth and
reconciling changes.
90% of G Suite files in
Enterprise accounts are shared,
and 74% of time spent in
Google Docs is collaborative.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
Likewise, we're
also focused on creating a
simpler and more efficient
experience for IT.
Less time is spent dealing
with legacy technology,
like patches and
software install cycles.
G Suite and Chromebooks can both
be managed from the Cloud-based
Google Admin console,
meaning reduced overhead
and ease of use for IT.
Smart defaults on
policies help limit
the time it takes to
configure your organization.
For example, most security
settings are on by default.
Finally, you can manage devices
with existing third party
tools, such as VMware,
Citrix, and more.
BRANDY AU: Finally,
Chrome OS helps
build on the intelligence
already found
in G Suite, focused on reducing
mundane tasks for the user.
With G Suite, users are able to
leverage Smart Reply and Smart
Compose to easily
get through emails,
or use the Explore
function in Sheets
to make the most out
of their data sets.
All the while, Chrome
OS performs tasks
like auto adjusting
screen brightness based
on ambient lighting or
optimizing power consumption
and memory management to adapt
to that user's work habits.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: And much
like Google Drive helps
to suggest files
for Quick Access,
Chrome OS is designed to enable
an efficient search experience.
For example, device launchers
optimize to recommend apps
based on recency and relevancy.
It can search across apps, web,
G Suite, and on device files,
with intelligent rankings
based on context, for example,
files you usually access only
at a specific time of the day.
BRANDY AU: As you can
see, G Suite customers
across many regions and segments
are adopting Chromebooks.
Let's look at a few in detail.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: In the
US, appliances manufacturer
Whirlpool has completely
overhauled its end point fleet
by equipping its workforce
with Chromebooks and G Suite.
The numbers speak
for themselves.
BRANDY AU: Square
adopted Pixelbooks,
which allowed staff to take
advantage of the G Suite
productivity apps and move
away from hard drive storage.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
And EMEA utilities
provider Veolia implemented its
[? SATAWA, ?] which is secure
anytime, anywhere,
any device program,
with the goal of moving
its workers to Chromebooks
and G Suite.
As a result, they've
been able to connect
their global workforce
more efficiently
and drastically reduce the
amount of IT overhead required.
BRANDY AU: Finally,
an APAC, Service NSW,
was able to greatly reduce
the support hours required
to maintain their
Microsoft environment when
switching to Chrome
Enterprise and G Suite.
Cloud-based services
enabled them
to eliminate unnecessary
additional layers
and collaborate more easily.
CHRISTOPHER JONES:
Cloud-based applications
are becoming more
and more prevalent,
and more and more organizations
are planning for their move
to the Cloud.
To help, SoftWatch
came up with CBAR,
a tool which shows real
users' application usage,
thus providing the relevant
data for decision makers.
CBAR can help recognize
the following--
Cloud workers, or
workers who are
ready to move to
the Cloud today;
potential Cloud workers, or
workers who could potentially
be Cloud workers;
desktop workers,
or workers that use non-web
applications to perform
their jobs.
CBAR displays the exact level
of dependency on non-web,
as well as web, applications,
to enable decision makers
to design a practical
plan for the mass adoption
of Chromebooks.
Additional functionality of
CBAR includes the following--
editing applications
lists, or defining
which applications can be
blacklisted, compatible,
or watch listed; application
tab, which demonstrates which
users use each
application; machines tab
provides machine information
and which machines belong
to which users; office usage
tab, which demonstrates
how many users use
office applications;
and finally, macro
usage tab, which
demonstrates how many users
use files with macros.
BRANDY AU: If you're
interested in getting started,
check out the
Forrester TEI report
or start a trial of
Chrome Enterprise
that you can use
with any Chromebook.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Thank you.
Please stay tuned
for the live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
less than one minute.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: Welcome back.
We're ready to dive
into some Q&A questions.
First question is, do
Chromebooks work offline?
That's a great question.
I think Chromebooks
have definitely
had a reputation in the past
of being internet-dependent.
Most of our fleet is a
high-memory, high-storage
device with powerful
processing, which
means you can actually run
applications in real time
on the Chromebook without
any internet connectivity.
Additionally, you can
work with your files that
are saved locally on
the Chromebook storage
or in your Google
Drive in offline mode.
So we have offline
mode for Gmail,
and we also have
offline mode for Drive.
You can view and edit Docs,
Sheets, and Slide files
using the offline mode.
And it's really as simple as
installing a Chrome extension
and activating offline mode.
I'm a frequent traveler, and
both Gmail and Drive offline
are tools that I leverage
quite frequently.
So that's question one.
Let's move on to
the second question.
Does Microsoft Office
work on a Chromebook?
Well, we hope you're doing most
of your editing in Google Docs
formats, but we understand
there may be a one-off need
to work in a Microsoft format.
You can save Microsoft native
formats on your Google Drive
and in local storage
on your Chromebook.
There are really three main ways
to work with Microsoft files
in the Google environment,
on a Chromebook, or in Drive.
The first is through your web
browser, the Chrome browser,
and with a sync client.
The second is to install
the Drive sync tool
in your Microsoft instance.
And the third is to upload the
Microsoft file to Google Drive
or on your Chromebook and use
Office Compatibility mode.
So you can do all of
your editing in Google
and move seamlessly
back and forth
between Google format
and Microsoft format.
[INAUDIBLE] number two.
BRANDY AU: Yep.
That was great.
There's another question
here asking about how
Chromebooks stay up to date.
So Chromebooks get automatic
updates from Google,
from the Cloud, every six weeks.
And so it really
takes the onus off
of IT admins to manually
patch and update the devices.
At the same time, IT admins
have complete control
over how those updates happen.
For example, you can pin some
devices to the current version,
if there are testing
and validation cycles
that you have to go through.
Or you can also time the
updates so that they're not
happening when all of your
users are on their devices.
So while the updates are
happening in the Cloud
and it takes the
onus off of you,
you can also completely
control how that happens
And then we have
another question here.
Do you need antivirus
software for Chromebooks?
So there's many layers of
built-in security on a Chrome
device that actually
preclude the need
for antivirus software.
And so a few examples of
that are, on the app layer,
all of our apps are read-only,
as well as the extensions,
so that they can't
modify the OS.
The sandboxing process we
talked about earlier isolates
malicious apps and
extensions, and so it really
limit the attack surface
available on a Chromebook.
On the OS level,
there's a concept
called verified boot, which,
whenever the device starts up,
it will always try to detect
whether that version of the OS
is safe.
And if it's not safe, then
we don't allow the Chromebook
to go into boot mode.
And then finally,
on a Chromebook,
all of the user data is
encrypted with our hardware
security module.
And that's built into
every Chrome device
that we manufacture.
And because of the fact that
users can't install executables
on a Chrome device, that
really reduces the chances
of malicious software getting
installed onto your device.
CHRISTOPHER JONES: All right.
Great.
It looks like that
concludes the Q&A list.
Thank you for tuning in.
Please visit Cloud OnAir
to discover more content
from Google Cloud experts.
Thank you.